impossible d'ignorer le bruit des avions
qui atterrissent ou qui décolle c'est la
réalité des résidents qui habitent en
périphérie de l'aéroport et dans le nord
de montréal non seulement le jour mais
aussi la nuit tiens la plus sûre à la
main là c'était un 4 4 5 la nuit des
fois aucun
puis maintenant c'est régulier de 10,15
à montréal les ordres d'exploitation des
gros appareils qui pèse plus de 45
tonnes et qui sont plus bruyants sont
limitées leur décollage est interdit
entre minuit et 7h et leur atterrissage
l'êtes aussi entre 1h et 7h mais selon
une compilation effectuée par un des
membres du groupe les polluer de
montréal trudeau 15 avions obtenu une
exemption chaque jour en moyenne entre
le 13 et le 26 juin pour décoller ou
atterrir en pleine nuit je peux
t'asseoir d'un tacot parce que les
avions passent conclut demain le jour
puis la nuit mais tu te réveiller par
les avions alors ça fait une situation
de vie très désagréable alors les gens
qu'est ce qu'ils font bien qu'un peu
qu'un rien peut plus ben qui m'étonne
pas catalan depuis les ménages
aéroports de montréal admet qu'un plus
grand nombre d'extensions cas d'habitude
ont été donnés depuis le début de l'été
elles peuvent être accordées en raison
des conditions météo comme à la mi juin
alors que des orages violents ont
provoqué l'annulation de 160 vols mais
c'est surtout le manque de personnel et
la désorganisation dans le secteur
aérien source de retards qui sont en
cause
tant qu'on ne peut pas absorber ça on
n'a qu'une solution soit le cheval ne
partent pas seuls les vols partent au
moment où le vol est prête à partir
selon un organisme qui analyse la
pollution sonore de bruit au sol pour
être atténués si les avions amorcé leur
virage après le décollage une plus haute
altitude
je sais que l'avion qui monte à 5
wickets va toucher les gens
sous le ter de montréal - qu'un avion à
3000 kg et je pense que cette changement
peut aider beaucoup mais entre-temps ont
plus de pénaliser les voyageurs le chaos
dans les aéroports pénalise aussi ceux
qui habitent aux alentours ici rivier
bachand radio canada montréal